manipulation plus réaction
la suicide en masse déjà en 2002 le
rédacteur en chef du journal turc publié
à Montréal dénoncer l'arrivée au pouvoir
de rejetta
on connaissait la formation politique et
de Monsieur Erdogan puis ils avaient
toujours une agenda caché
une mère eu zen s'est fait un devoir de
dénoncer la corruption qui régnait dans
le pays mais depuis qu'ils sont là cette
pierre il faut rassembler ce peuple tout
entière pour le journalisme les
élections du 14 mai en Turquie sont
cruciales une importance que confirme
les experts c'est la première fois que
ce sont des élections sérieuses et
serrées
[Musique]
affronte une opposition maintenant
solidaire une coalition s'est formée
l'alliance de la nation avait objective
de se débarrasser du pouvoir en place
c'est un référendum autour de la
personnalité de Monsieur ardogan de sa
présidente qui a un certain moment avéré
à être plus un pouvoir autoritaire au
détriment de la démocratie turque
une lutte serrée qui interpelle la
diaspora turque montréalaise si bien
qu'ils sont nombreux à voter un
engouement sans précédent
aux élections cette fois-ci
est arrivé au Québec il y a un peu plus
de 10 ans elle n'a connu que le pouvoir
d'erdoine notre jeunesse est passé avec
la même personne on veut voir autre
chose on veut entendre d'autres choses
on veut la démocratie bien sûr son goal
n'a aussi connu kerdo one nationaliste
elle souligne la prospérité de son pays
depuis 20 ans le président n'est pas à
blâmer selon elle pour l'inflation qui
afflige le pays plus important
pas économique nous c'est le plus
important c'est le pays reste une pays
c'est l'heure avec le son drapeau
[Musique]
de vision de la Turquie qui s'affrontent
et qui se retrouvent sur toutes les
lèvres au restaurant de shérif mais il y
a des Turcs il y a des cœurs
parce que chacun pense différente le
restaurateur espère la chute d'erdouan
mais craint qu'elle laisse un goût amer
on espère que
les parties opposées devraient rester
très fort très solide parce que on sait
que cette soirée là ça va ça peut
arriver plein de choses oui il y a des
craintes assez justifiées qu'il pourrait
peut-être contester quand même assez
vigoureusement le résultat
c'est un scénario qu'appréhende un maire
mais il essaie de ne pas y penser cette
fois-ci ça change on va le réussir
absolument pour l'instant il sent la
brise d'espoir un rêve qu'il portera
jusqu'au 14 mai du mois ici Marie José
paquet de Comores au Canada Montréal